[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
every boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
now I have the pleasure of introducing
two of our very own students katara
Garcia a senior mechanical engineering
and I honest a mules a graduate student
and Aeronautics and Astronautics who
will guide us in a reflection of the
life and legacy of dr. King
[Applause]
[Music]
we will first hear from Katara Garcia
class of 2003 kateri Thank You Michelle
good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is Katara Garcia and I am a senior
in the department of mechanical
engineering and I'm currently the
president of the Society of Hispanic
Professional Engineers I am honored
yet humbled to stand here today to
reflect upon and pay homage to one of
our nation's most courageous and
inspirational heroes dr. Martin Luther
King jr. dr. King will perhaps forever
be known in our histories texts as the
man with the dream I have a dream he
said that my four little children will
one day live in a nation where they will
not be judged by the content by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character 40 years later we
quote dr. King with the presumption that
time has fully realized his dream though
time has indeed seen our nation through
great transformation even the course of
four decades has not been enough to
realize the dream and today's theme
faces at the bottom of the well the
nightmare of reality versus dr. King's
dream reminds us that reminds us that
social injustice is not necessarily a
dysfunction of our history but rather a
tragedy of the present social inequality
is an issue that we face today and the
dream voiced by dr. King four decades
ago is still only a dream today the
dream was to make all citizens of the
United States truly equal as we take
time to reflect upon the changes of our
nation since the days of slavery since
the Emancipation Proclamation since the
days of the Jim Crow laws that created
segregation since the passing of the
13th and the 14th and the 15th
amendments to our Constitution it
appears as though we have
volved from the days of racial
discrimination but as Derrick Bell
author of faces at the bottom of the
well points out our laws have changed
but the sentiment of hatred and
misunderstanding is still in the hearts
of many when we look at the faces of the
CEOs of corporate America at the
justices of the courts at the astronauts
at the presidents of these United States
we see that faces of color and women are
frightfully underrepresented racial
disparities from top executives to the
unemployed reflect the presence of the
complacent attitude that allows us to
settle for less than we started out
towards and prevents us from the
Equality for which we dream improvements
in representation need to start with our
educational system the dropout rate of
American high school students especially
among minorities is alarming the 2000
report from the National Center for
Educational statistics shows that while
approximately 92 percent of all white
students complete high school only 84
percent of African Americans will
graduate and the completion rate for
Hispanics is a shocking 64 percent
trends show that this gap is not closing
at the same time those students who do
graduate from high school only one-third
of those minority students will go on to
college and among those only about 50%
will make it through let's look at MIT
x' record MIT has been very successful
in attracting and maintaining a higher
percentage of minority undergraduate
students from 1980 it had only about 7%
but today it makes up about 18% of the
population however the rate of graduate
students and faculty has continued at a
mere 3% the disparities in these
statistics are part of the nightmare of
reality and to those who do succeed in
college many minorities and
international students fill the
pressures of not only having to succeed
for ourselves but for also the people
who we represent
if we fail we fail all those who will
come after us minorities in America are
the faces at the bottom of societies
well African Americans Native Americans
and Hispanics are underrepresented and
underpaid in virtually all professions
society system is such that the odds are
completely against us yet red flags are
being raised against affirmative action
in programs such as mites and project
interface to keep us down even longer
the moment that a minority person rises
to the top of the well the people at the
top let go of the rope and call us
under-qualified too conservative or too
liberal what they really mean is we are
not white enough and sometimes to those
in our own communities
we are not Hispanic enough or black
enough why do we keep holding ourselves
down at the bottom of the well instead
of helping each other to climb out look
around you the faces at the bottom of
the well are no different from you or me
or anyone else in this room ask
yourselves how you beat the odds and
made it to and through MIT and when you
leave this place will you return to the
communities that you left behind like
dr. King will we face the challenge and
return to the south or will we forget
that we too were once faces at the
bottom of the well dr. King is one of
the most visionary and fearless men of
his time and of times to come it was
with his courage to return to the south
and be an instrument of hope an
earthmoving change that he was able to
carry forward the strides towards civil
rights economic equality and social
justice for all but he could not have
done it alone dr. King used his
god-given talents to unite people of all
colors all religions he didn't say it's
not my problem but he dared to put his
dreams into action he embraced the
challenge and he sent down his bucket to
the bottom of the well time and time
again dr. King's dream lives on and will
continue to come true as long as we make
dr. dream Kings dreams of freedom
justice and equality our own dreams as
long as we continue as he did to help
pull up those faces at the bottom of the
well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You kateri we're not here for my
honest Samuel Ayane
[Applause]
Thank You Michelle ladies and gentlemen
good morning I must thank all involved
in giving me the opportunity to speak
this morning a personal thank you to
Professor bond dr. Martin Luther King
and all the others who fought and died
for the civil rights and opportunities
that I know enjoy as a black person from
another country Jamaica the very last
issue that dr. King tackled before his
death was that of poverty he rightly
stated in 1967 that the vast majority of
Negro brothers are smothering in an
airtight cage of poverty in the midst of
an affluent society
sadly 36 years later due progress has
not been observed this rightly giving
birth to today's theme what is the
nightmare of today's reality you might
ask debilitating and grinding poverty
that afflicts people of all races colors
and nationalities and change them to the
bluest rung of the economic ladder if
one were to take the time to pare down
at the faces at the bottom of the well
you would find that poverty is neither
racist nor sexist nor nationalistic
Jarrett Bell's book based on today's
theme informs us that the u.s. income
earners in the top fifth earn more than
those their counterparts in the bottom
four faiths combined it would be remiss
of me not to mention that there are
disproportionate amounts of minorities
in the lowest one-fifth who are burdened
with lifelong poverty and soil
devastating despair the permanence of
this situation is largely due to the
fact that attitude
and public policies associated with
slavery have failed to fade away
that is the grim reality to borrow from
the late Bob Marley it is a sort of
mental slavery that keeps us at the
bottom of the well and will detain us
there unless we begin to realize that we
all have to swim together or sink
together
unemployment in accessible healthcare
immigration policies inadequate housing
in equal access to quality education and
excess mortality of more minorities due
to AIDS speaks to the tragedy of our
times in addition there are
astronomically high rates of
incarceration of minority men a study
recently completed by the Justice policy
institutes reported that there were
nearly 200,000 more black men in prison
than in college
among the ages 18 to 24 there are only
two point six times as many black men in
college as in the prison the number on
death row is equally as astounding for
their white male counterparts there are
28 times as many in college as in prison
these statistics sum up to an incredible
waste of human and economic resources
which over time depletes the social and
family structure and ultimately results
in a lack of belief of the validity of
one's existence suffice it to say that
it is not only the faces at the bottom
of the well that are disallowed from
achieving their full potential
no matter one's credentials nor how much
those that came before you may have
sacrificed to afford you a good
education proper health care and the
sonne belief in your ability research
has shown that the American populace
phil has a hard time looking beyond the
color of one skin in an MIT and
University of Chicago research project
5,000 resumes were sent to 1250
recruiting companies in many instances
identically very able and qualified
applicants applied for the same job with
the only difference being in there
having either black or white sounding
names
the results were alarming resumes with a
white name had a 50% higher response
rate than their black counterparts what
does this mean the nightmare of reality
is that lynching has moved from our
great-grandparents as front yards to the
corporate boardroom
then there is the issue of affirmative
action dr. King must be turning in his
grave to see our leaders misusing his
ideals to oppose inherent goals of
affirmative action
unfortunately the term has long suffered
from definitional drift affirmative
action exists to address centuries of
past discrimination and the effects of
present discrimination based on race
gender disabilities age and religious
affiliation as President Clinton once
said the answer is not to end it but to
mend it the real issue is in the details
of implementation the methods of
implementation must be examined to
ensure that they are not just mechanic's
percentages but that they ensure they
adhere rather took legal and ethical
standards it is imperative that in
tandem with such efforts we seek to mend
America's educational system from the
k-12 level disparities and resources and
opportunities along race and class lines
must be mitigated with urgency regarding
diversity simply stated it is a must as
Dean of Admissions Marley Jones said
recently engineers need to come from
everywhere to solve the problems of
people everywhere
we're dr. King here today with respect
to the issue of the war in Iraq being
such a vehement support of non-violent
confrontation I think you would agree
with the UN that any action taken should
be the results of proper investigation
and consensus it is interesting to note
that in preparation for war minorities
and the poor are overwhelmingly
represented and gave their lives in the
Vietnam War
much more than non minorities throughout
all these atrocities one tenant remain
it's true simply time and the generosity
of people will not solve our race class
and economic problems in order to turn
today's nightmare into dr. King's dream
we need to cease from turning a blind
eye to the wails of the economically
deprived at the bottom of the well as
dr. King once said the curse of poverty
has no justification in our age and must
be hastily relinquished a major
inhabitant to social progress is that
the don't trodden among us irrespective
of race class or creed refused to
realize the necessity of each other's
existence in the quest to make it out of
the well some even gained their
self-esteem by peering down at those at
the bottom of the well dr. King was a
firm believer in the fact that human
progress never rolls in on the wheels of
inevitability it is only when whites and
all minority groups work in coalition
that we can truly affect change escape
from the well and rise from the dark
depths of racism and Prejudice to the
majestic heights of understanding and
brotherhood however there must be the
knowledge that this will be fiercely
opposed by the status quo recently the
census Peru indicated that there are no
more Hispanics than blacks in America
instead of celebrating an increase in
diversity the sentiment of the media has
been that the african-american
population should be concerned that
Hispanics could no possibly replace them
in societal concerns this is a not so
subtle attempt to pit both groups
against each other nothing could be more
tragic than first to return to such
ideals at this time we must instead
think about how we can collectively
assist each other in embedding the
social fabric
America dr. King had the audacity to
believe that people's everywhere should
have three meals a day for their body
education and culture for their minds
and dignity equality and freedom for
their spirits
unfortunately he was assassinated before
he could see his dream realized as such
his tombstone reads free at last free at
last thank God Almighty I am free at
last
thus I implore you let not dr. King's
dreams and significance dwindle to a
mere symbol to add to our the uncashed
checks handed down to those that suffer
let not another face at the bottom of
the well have to drown in their own
despair before they can finally say that
they are free at last let us prove that
you can assassinate the messenger but
you cannot assassinate the dream
remember human progress never rolls in
on wheels of inevitability did you hear
me human progress never rolls in on
wheels of inevitability once more human
progress never rolls in and will never
roll in on wheels of inevitability thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You Ayane once again I would like
to thank both Katara Garcia and I honest
a muse for their wonderful remarks and
letting the words of dr. King be heard
once more
I hope that everyone here today has
really had a chance to listening
carefully now I have the honor of
introducing Chancellor Philip M clay who
presented the 2002-2003 MLK Leadership
Awards Chancellor clay
[Applause]
it's always a speaker's nightmare to
follow such elephants
I'm delighted that I only have one
sentence to give and I'll try to do it
well for the issues dear to us and for
our world this is a period of maximum
challenge but I have the pleasant task
of leading us into recognizing and
celebrating the champions among us
that's my speech
with Professor Jonathan king please come
forward
johnathan your colleagues cited your
long history of advocacy for democratic
direction of science and technology
you're deeply respected as a scientist
and as a teacher who possesses a clear
and insistent voice one often raised
against the growing trends to alienate
price and privatized information that
should be the legacy of humankind your
enduring commitment to promoting greater
public awareness of crucial scientific
issues has given the average citizen a
clearer understanding of matters
concerned with stem cell research bio
prophecy and genetically modified foods
as a scholar and mentor in this
community you have inspired countless
students and colleagues to look closely
at the implications of their own work
you have generously shared your
knowledge and insight with others by
organizing Massachusetts parents to
improve public school systems and by
serving as a Linus Pauling lecturer at
Clark University a historically black
institution in Atlanta because of your
dedication to creating better standards
of living for all human beings the MLK
committee firmly believes that you are
working to sustain dr. King's dream with
that I'm delighted to present you with
this Martin Luther King
I also want to acknowledge the presence
of mrs. King and their two sons and
thank them for sharing Jonathan with us
I want to thank the committee for the
support and all of those among you who
wrote letters of support I want to
credit the people in my research lab who
have always been supportive and never
complained at least to me about time
spent on issues outside the research lab
they've been many graduate students
postdoctoral fellows undergraduates but
particularly I want to note my longtime
associates cami huzi Pettingill and
Cindy Wooley through the years at MIT
colleagues Mel King Steve Charles's got
paradise Vera Castilla Kowski Willard
Johnson Leon trilling many others some
no longer with us were allies to many on
campus and off-campus struggles and were
very important resource Jackie Dee King
my wife has been at my side since I've
been at MIT I don't want to say I've
been at MIT for 33 years
and she's been at my side it's thick and
thin through all that time and our sons
Andrew and Aaron have been good comrades
along the way and kind of sensitized me
to the struggles of young people family
friends larry and awarder are here and
others in Cambridge have been on the
side in struggles in Cambridge now when
I was growing up in high school and
college and graduate school images of
Martin Luther King walking and marching
dominated you know the life outside the
the classes but there's a particular
component of his leadership that I would
call forward today when during the
escalation of the war in Vietnam he
stepped forward and told the nation that
we couldn't be fighting for justice at
home while prosecuting an unjust war
against the Vietnamese people and he
stated so clearly that the bombs that
are dropped abroad also take that toll
at home and in this period when a
reckless administration puts all of us
at risk we need to follow his leadership
and resist an unwise unjust an uncalled
for war once again and I hope
but Hector Hernandez come forward the
nominators in your case cited your
promising research and biotechnology and
your exceptional ability to motivate
young scholars majoring in science as a
teaching assistant in biochemistry in a
biochemistry course for undergraduates
and for graduate students you took on
the challenging task of teaching an
assignment in a department in an
emerging field you demonstrated a strong
commitment to undergraduate research by
training five students from diverse
backgrounds a young woman who worked
under your supervision for a summer was
inspired to apply to MIT and is now
completing her first year of graduate
studies here because of your superb
range of talents and your solid
contributions to the community you've
been given many citations and your peers
have elected you as chair elect of the
chemistry students graduate council the
MLK committee believes that your
leadership and your service to others
embody the essence of dr. King's ideals
[Applause]
Wow this is really pretty um I was kind
of really taken aback when I heard that
I had wounded won this award it was um
nothing that I have ever dreamed of
because you always see other people
doing so much of the work and stuff so
I'm really honored I want to thank the
committee for giving me this honor to be
here today I want to thank my professor
professor Kathy Drennan for um really
turning her cheek and turning her eye
when I'm out of the lab a lot doing a
lot of things other than researching
chemistry um I want to thank uh Susan
Brighton she's standing over there in
the corner and we're sitting down there
she's armed like the mother had in the
chemistry department taking care of the
students and given us a guiding a
guiding voice in an ear when we have to
go deal with some things I'm I want to
thank professor John Esserman for all
the support that he's provided me I want
to thank the chemistry department for
really taking a step forward in these
past couple of years with the issues of
minorities and under underrepresented
minorities in um in the sciences
particularly in chemistry they were
dominant and implemented some really
really good programs that have allowed
people to come work in the department
during the summers again I want to thank
the selection committee it's been an
honor and they told me to keep it short
so I'll say a couple more words and
that's it I want to thank my mother
[Applause]
they're all written down
my mom was an incredible woman come
ensure that everybody who's ever been a
good leader can say that they can't do
it without their parents or their mother
and so on she's very happy for me and
she started that she's gonna be here
fear is a very strong motivating factor
particularly in this day and age when
we're facing fear of war fear of foreign
people in our land and fear of getting
up the next day and not knowing what's
gonna happen
out-out him I'm on the world among us
one of the things that I can say is that
fear is something that people try to use
to keep us down and we need to get over
that we need to have strength we need to
come out it's hard to do that sometimes
because everything you see on TV you
know from our leaders and from our peers
even in our departments kind of make us
feel like we are not the norm we're
people who have yet to be accepted in
their fields sometimes we feel that
we're here because we're just a number
and somebody's trying to fill a gap
because it looks bad I can assure you
that at MIT that is not the case I've
been accepted here I mean I people
really do care I'm the minority
Scholastic Scholar Program here is very
very good all I want to say is that we
need to support programs like Mike we
need support professors like Kathy
Joyner professors like Jonathan King
professors like John Essendon and
countless of others that I have no idea
who they are but I know work behind the
scenes and I hope the school really
takes this to heart and really keeps
these programs going for us thank you
very much
we miss Chiquita white please come
forward
[Applause]
your alumni colleagues have cited your
committed and long-standing interest in
developing students as candidates for
careers in industry as Procter &
Gamble's head recruiter for MIT and
school team leader in your company you
have tires tirelessly help young people
to prepare for professional employment
by closely interacting with students in
our Mann office of minority education
and second summer program your counsel
has motivated many to seek meaningful
paths which without your efforts might
have been overlooked your work is a
fundraiser for the class of 1985 and
your memberships on the boards of BAM it
and the Alumni Alumni Association have
distinguished you as one who firmly
believes in giving back to the community
the MLK committee greatly recognizes
your desire to improve the lives of our
students and alumni as a significant
part of dr. King's cherished vision for
institutions like MIT and I want to also
welcome your parents who are here and
acknowledge that your sister is an
alumna and so we have beyond it to
opportunity to honor and a MIT family
very nice Valentine's Day gift from
Institute that I love so thank you I'm
honored and humbled to be selected for
such a prestigious award my nomination
was a complete surprise to me and I
truly appreciate being recognized as
something I simply enjoy doing coming to
campus meeting students and talking
about a job that I love I want to thank
the MLK committee and the ome for
selecting me as a recipient and I also
want to thank my parents but told the
committee last night my parents
instilled at me at a young age the value
of giving back to your community
recently I read I think it was in
essence one of my plane flights back and
forth that when you have a mission of
service that brings a balance to your
life and I really you know that
resonated with me and I believe that
because the service part of my life is a
thing that gives me great joy I hope
that as I continue to live my life that
I will continue to give back to others
and be an inspiration to others so that
they can do the same thing so thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much and congratulations
for recipients of this year's MLK
leadership award I would like at this
time to welcome back to MIT gospel choir
[Music]
I'm in the sky I'm gonna tell this world
goodbye you see I'm gonna fly your way
we're gonna be caught up together to
live with Jesus Christ forever you see
I'm gonna fly away now I will be free
[Applause]
one day
Hey I will be free
I've got a home in the sky gonna tell
this world goodbye but you see I'm gonna
away we're gonna be cold up together to
live with Jesus Christ forever
you see I'm gonna fly away and I will be
free
one day
hey I will be free
one
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll be free
[Music]
[Applause]
now it gives me great pleasure to
introduce the 15th president of MIT
president Charles em vest president vest
president vest will give some remarks
and proceeded to produce our keynote
speaker mr. Julian Bond president vet
[Applause]
[Music]
this may be the coldest day of the year
outside but I think it's the warmest day
of the year in here and you all know
it's Valentine's Day and you've probably
heard that Monday's Presidents Day but
what you may not know is Monday is
Michelle's birthday thank you all for
joining us in this annual MIT tradition
it's always one of the highlights of the
year and we're delighted to have with us
this morning so many distinguished
representatives not just of MIT itself
but of the Greater Cambridge community
and in particular I want to recognize
the presence of director of Economic
Development Estella Johnson representing
the city of Cambridge and we are also
joined by the presidents of the Boston
and Cambridge chapters of the n-double
a-c-p
Leonard Elkins and Cathy Reddick thank
you very much for being with us
as we gather on this morning in February
2003 to celebrate the life and teachings
of the doctor of dr. Martin Luther King
there are many things I would like to
talk about but one topic is of such
timeliness and importance to this
institution and to the values of
American higher education as I see them
that I shall limit my remarks
to addressing it recently I asked a
friend of mine who had attended the
World Economic Forum in Davos what his
reaction had been to secretary Powell's
well-publicized speech here's his answer
he said whether I agree or disagree with
his arguments regarding Iraq I am really
proud that : Powell is our secretary of
state and as each of us watched as the
heartbreaking tragedy of the space
shuttle Columbia played out
I suspect we had a common reaction this
group of astronauts looks an awful lot
like the students in the hallways of MIT
increasingly looks like America in 2003
for us the tragedy was compounded
because seeing their images was like
looking in a mirror with pride now how
did Colin Powell become Secretary of
State and how did Michael Anderson Orca
or Kalpana
tralala or Laurel Clark come to be
voyagers in space they achieved their
goal by talent determination and drive
the same way that Rick husband or Pete
McCool or David Brown did it they
achieved their goals the same way that
MIT alumnus and earlier Secretary of
State George Shultz did it the same way
that Buzz Aldrin Ron McNair Ken Cameron
Franklin chang-diaz Janice Voss Cady
Coleman or any of the other 31
astronauts who are MIT graduates
did it but all of these wonderful people
the pride of our nation had the
opportunity to develop their talent and
to translate their determination and
drive into accomplishment in America
education is our primary vehicle of
opportunity opportunity to develop human
talent to bring coherence to drive and
to convert determination into
accomplishment it was not long ago that
access to America's opportunity and
particularly access to our great system
of public and private universities would
not have been readily available to :
powell or michael anderson or kalpana
tralala or Laurel Clark today it is but
will it be tomorrow the answer to that
question lies at the heart of a landmark
legal battle that will be settled within
a few months by the Supreme Court of the
United States bankrolled and spurred on
by two so-called watchdog groups a
lawsuit has been brought against the
University of Michigan regarding its
policies and processes for admitting
students to its law school and to its
undergraduate college of literature
science and arts the goal of that suit
now before the Supreme Court is to
remove from colleges and universities
their freedom to consider race as one of
many factors when admitting students
along the thread of that seemingly
simple phrase race as one of many
factors hangs the fate of opportunity
for many future American citizens of
color on the thread of that seemingly
simple phrase race is one of many
factors hangs the ability of MIT to
explicitly pursue the goal declared in
our mission statement that says MIT is
dedicated to providing its students with
an education that combines rigorous
academic study and the excitement of
discovery
with the support and intellectual
stimulation of a diverse campus
community on the thread of that
seemingly simple phrase race is one of
many factors hangs the freedom of
faculties of American universities to
apply standards and principles of their
choosing to the most basic of academic
decisions the decision of who shall
study in their universities that thread
that seemingly simple phrase race as one
of many factors was spun by justice
Powell when he wrote the majority
opinion for the Supreme Court in 19th in
the 1978 case of Regents of the
University of California versus baki
in the next few months the Rehnquist
court must decide whether that thread
will remain whole or whether with one
snip of the judicial scissors they will
sever it and let educational opportunity
for many students of color crash back to
the floor
the floor from which it has been raised
with such effort over so many decades
friends we must preserve the legal right
and moral authority to consider race as
one of many factors in college and
university admissions and in other
programs and dimensions of our life and
learning why do I care I care because of
what I have experienced and learned in a
lifetime as a student and educator and I
care because MIT must be a leader and a
moral force I care because when I look
out this morning at the members of the
MIT community who are gathered here I
know where we are and I know how we got
here when I began my career as a
graduate student Teaching Fellow and
then as a young assistant professor at
the University of Michigan in the 1960s
it was extraordinary if I had more than
one african-american student in my class
every couple of years in fact it was
extraordinary if I had more than one or
two women students in a class and if I
had either it was a lead-pipe cinch that
they would be one of the best two or
three students in the class because only
through extraordinary Drive and
commitment with these students have come
to study engineering in that context
when I look around MIT at its student
body today whose undergraduates are 42%
women or 6% african-american 11%
Hispanic American and even 2% Native
American a student body that is
remarkably diverse in so many other
dimensions as well it sometimes seems to
me that a miracle has happened but that
is just the point it is not a miracle
it's not a natural occurrence this is
the result of determined conscientious
effort over more than three decades
often against seemingly insurmountable
odds it is the result of institutional
leadership and occasional courage it is
the result of the determination of
innumerable families and communities the
goal was as simple as it was profound to
give every young person the opportunity
to succeed I can only conclude that
despite the length of the journey our
nation is in a better place than it was
three decades ago but my own journey and
experience is not one of just watching
numbers slowly move in the right
direction it is one of direct and
meaningful personal benefit from
diversity I grew up in West Virginia a
border state not quite of the south but
not quite of the north either I attended
racially segregated schools until I was
in junior high school our schools were
desegregated in one fell swoop a year or
so ahead of brown versus
Board of Education I came quickly to
value and learn from the new classmates
who joined us I remember when our high
school football coach drilled us on how
to protect our black teammates should
they be attacked in some of the more
rural towns in which we were to play my
first science teacher who was a big
inspiration was black my high school
physics teacher was a woman my closest
friend in graduate school was from India
my PhD thesis advisor was from Turkey
my closest colleagues is a young
professor from Taiwan and Hungary and
Turkey
as well as from America my own father
grew up in a household in which German
was spoken I know that I am richer that
my worldview is more balanced and that
my ability to do my job and live my life
have been greatly enhanced by these and
so many more personal experiences that
we could file under the heading of
diversity most of these things I suspect
seemed to the students with us today
like the air you breathe or the water
you drink what's the big deal you might
ask well it is a big deal because it
hasn't always been that way it got that
way as I said because of determined
conscientious effort over more than
three decades often against seemingly
insurmountable odds but race still
matters in America there are still
forces that drive racial isolation we
haven't reached the day when we truly
have a race blind Society we hope we
will but we haven't and we must not put
our head in the sand declare victory and
let thirty years of progress slide
through our fingers experience in
California and elsewhere shows that when
race is removed as an explicit factor
among many in admissions decision
minority opportunity in the most
competitive institutions suffers that is
why I care about preserving the rights
of colleges and universities to consider
race as one of many factors in
admissions and in our ethos why do I
care I care because MIT for decades has
been a leader in building the diversity
of our own community and of the
engineering and science workforce and
leadership of America and it is not
going to lose that edge on my watch
mit has historically been illegal
more broadly more broadly across US
universities interestingly it was
engineering schools that tended to lead
the way in the early 1970s
we established outreach programs like
mites to attract young Hispanic American
african-american and Native American
high school students to the engineering
profession a career that tended not to
benefit from a high degree of awareness
in their communities I don't believe
that we saw this task as one of
political orientation or ideology we saw
it as an important duty to our nation we
saw it as a problem to be solved a
design to be improved and it flowed
naturally from our connection to
industry an American industry provided
and today continues to provide most of
the financial support and summer
experiences that make such programs work
in supporting these programs and our
admission policies corporations have not
done so because they are liberal or
conservative Democrats or Republicans
they support them because they
understand that our world is racially
diverse and if they are to understand
their customers produce well-designed
relevant products and market them
effectively they need the perspectives
and experiences of a workforce and
leadership that is diverse but we must
also contend with today's legal
landscape with the law of the land
during the last several months we at MIT
have learned this the hard way
the complaint filed against us led to a
review of to MIT pre-college summer
programs by the US Department of
Education Office of Civil Rights the two
highly valued programs as you well know
mites the minority introduction to
engineering entrepreneurship and science
and interface
myk's is an outreach program that
provides intense education and career
experience for high school juniors
interested in science mathematics and
engineering interphase is a bridge
program for incoming MIT freshmen we at
MIT are very proud of the decades of
accomplishment of these two programs
they have served hundreds indeed
thousands of promising young men and
women very well we pledge to you that
they will continue to serve promising
minority students in the future but our
rigorous examination and the best advice
of literally every legal expert we
sought out was unequivocal and led us to
conclude that we should not continue to
limit participation in these programs
only to underrepresented minority
students therefore we will broaden the
selection criteria to include other
students whose backgrounds may otherwise
stand in the way of their studying
science and engineering but as we do so
we will find ways to continue to meet
our underlying goal of fostering the
education and opportunities of as many
bright underrepresented minority
students as possible this is MIT after
all and I am confident that with the
help of our faculty and students we will
continue to exercise leadership and
build programs that will do just that
and we will be as proud of these
programs in the future as we are today
much has been written about the value of
diversity of educate of the education of
all students on American campuses its
value is well documented by serious
social science as well as by the more
anecdotal experiential testimony
students and graduates but most such to
such studies have tended to focus on the
liberal arts and on the professions of
law
in medicine but what do we think here at
MIT with our pervasive environment of
science and engineering
we know statistically exactly what our
students and graduates think our surveys
find that almost 70% of the MIT class of
believed that relating well to people of
different races cultures and religions
is either very important or essential
less than 5 percent considered it not to
be important furthermore 53% of the
class of 2000 - felt that their ability
to relate well to people of different
races cultures and religions was
stronger or much stronger when they
graduated than when they arrived at MIT
as freshmen less than 2 percent felt
weaker in this regard than when they
arrived does this mean that all students
at MIT hold the same beliefs about
affirmative action and race-conscious
policies and admissions and so forth of
course not our community has a wide
range of views and I would have it no
other way but the data show clearly that
we have an extremely strong consensus on
the goal and value of diversity how do
we achieve that goal schools like MIT or
Stanford University first establish
which of their applicants cross a very
high bar of quality based on measures
such as grades test scores and class
rank regardless of race or any other
characteristic then we make the
difficult subjective choices from among
those applicants who have crossed that
high bar of academic quality by
assessing as best we can the whole
person race is one of many factors
considered at this stage in order to
build an understanding of who each
person
is and the context in which they have
demonstrated accomplishment creativity
and drive now imagine if you will that
it was your job to work on admitting the
MIT class of 2008 you're preparing to
read and evaluate the folders of
thousands of applicants what's your task
you have the task of selecting only
about 15% from a pool of young men and
women who virtually all as I said have
outstanding test scores and grades and
the usual metrics so to focus your
thinking about selecting the class from
among these outstanding applicants you
take many slips of paper and on each one
you write a characteristic of the class
that you think is important and then you
array them on the table in front of you
the slips have listed characteristics
such as grades class rank standardized
test scores
geography gender economic status
creativity race leadership nationality
risk-taking musical talent life
experiences cultural background type of
high school special skills quality of
admissions essay ability to work in
teams evaluations by teachers and
counselors reports of our own alumni
educational counselors and so forth but
suddenly the arm of the federal
government reaches in grabs that one
slip on which race is written slaps you
on the wrist and sternly says you can
consider all those other factors but you
can't take race into account how can you
not consider race it is an integral part
of the individual identity of each
applicant and it helps us to understand
the context of their accomplishment and
their goals that is the world that we
will enter if the Bakke decision is
overturned this spring in such a world
we will dramatically slow our journey
to create a nation that is full that is
fair and full of justice for all it
would be a world in which higher
education cannot contribute maximally to
developing our nation's workforce its
scholars were the leaders of the next
generation across the full sweep of our
society next week
MIT will enter a brief as a friend of
the court in order to help persuade the
justices of the Supreme Court that for
the good of America our colleges and
universities must retain the freedom to
consider race as one of many factors
when admitting students
[Music]
you see that is what MIT can do that is
how MIT can state we are present and
accounted for that is how we can and
we'll put our oar in the water our brief
will make four primary points first the
interest of colleges and universities
including those with strong focus on
science and engineering in achieving
diversity of our student bodies and
academic communities is compelling in
many respects second we must retain our
freedom to consider race as one of many
factors in admitting students in order
to achieve this diversity third this is
true for both private and public
institutions and fourth a diverse
workforce and future leadership in
science and engineering will be
essential to our country's economic
strength will our brief have an impact
is it an important statement I think so
indeed last week the CEO and the
leadership team of one of America's
largest and best-known corporations sat
in a room discussing the importance of
the University of Michigan case one of
the groups said no matter which way this
case is decided by the Supreme Court in
the future people are going to look back
at our company and they're going to ask
where were you
they then decided to take a public
stance by joining the amicus brief
drafted and organized by MIT indeed our
arguments will be greatly strengthened
by the small but extremely important
group of amici who will join us by
signing our brief joining us will be
Stanford University the National Action
Council for minorities and engineering
or knack me do Paul
IBM the National Academy of Science and
the National Academy of Engineering
[Music]
two great universities the largest
National Consortium for advancing
engineering careers from minorities two
of the largest and best-known
technology-based companies in the world
and the two most prestigious academies
of science and engineering will be
standing together in a very highly
public manner when the question is asked
where were you
mi t--'s answer will be clear thank you
very much
thank you
it is a great privilege it is a great
privilege to introduce this morning's
distinguished guest speaker he has been
a leading light in the struggle for
civil rights and racial equality in
America for more than four decades
Julian bonds career as an activist began
when he was still a student at Morehouse
College where one of his teachers was
dr. Martin Luther King the protests
Julian Bond organized as an
undergraduate played a pivotal role in
desegregating movie theatres lunch
counters and parks in Atlanta he himself
was arrested for sitting in the
segregated for sitting in in the
segregated cafeteria in Atlantis City
Hall in 1960 he helped create the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee and then proceeded to work in
voter registration drives in Alabama
Arkansas Georgia and Mississippi Mr Bond
was elected to the Georgia Legislature
in 1965 and again in 1966 but on both
occasions he was denied his seat because
of his outspoken opposition to the
Vietnam War he finally took his seat
after the US Supreme Court ruled
unanimously the Georgia house had
violated his rights he went on to serve
a total of 20 years in the Georgia House
and Senate in 1968 he co-chaired a
successful challenge delegation from
Georgia to the democratic party's
national convention he himself was
nominated for vice president but
withdrew his name because he was too
young to serve
in 1971 mr. bond became the founding
president of the Southern Poverty Law
Center today he serves as chair of the
n-double a-c-p and teaches at American
University and at the University of
Virginia many of you know Julian Bond
from his thoughtful comments on
America's black forum others among you
will recognize his voice for he narrated
the extraordinary documentaries eye on
the prize and a time for justice
wherever and whenever he speaks he seeks
to tell America the truth about race
relations please join me in welcoming
Julian Bond
I do
thank you dr. Bess for your kind
introduction and thank you particularly
for your forthright statement and the
action you announced today it is a mark
of great distinction for MIT that you
are her president thank you a great
great deal for what MIT will do miss
Samuels and miss Garcia and the other
Award recipients have given my speech
but I'm gonna try to carry on you heard
dr. vests a moment ago that I was a
student of Martin Luther King's and when
I received this invitation I thought
surely that was the reason why that
people here at MIT knew about my close
personal intimate relationship with the
premier civil rights leader of the 20th
century and if you don't know about it
I'm gonna tell you about it right now
dr. King talked one time in his life at
Morehouse College taught one class six
people in the class I'm one of the six
so I'm one of six people in the whole
universe who can honestly say I was a
student of Martin Luther King now I wish
I could tell you I took extensive notes
in class and I've kept those notes until
today but I didn't do that well I wish I
could tell you I've had the wit to bring
a tape recorder to class and I'd tape
recorded these pearls of wisdom that
fell from the lips of this marvelous man
but I didn't do that either in fact I
remember nothing that pass between
teacher and student in the class but I
do remember one day class was over he
and I were walking across the beautiful
beautiful Morehouse College campus and I
turned to him and I said doc his friends
called him doc I said doc how you doing
he said Julian I'm not doing well said
unemployment is high segregation seems a
movable racism as everywhere I feel
awful he said I have a nightmare
I said no doc turned that around I have
a dream and
[Applause]
and we are here we are here today in
celebration of the life and legacy of
dr. King in April of 1954 he preached
his first sermon as pastor of
Montgomery's Dexter Avenue Baptist
Church he was 25 years old he could not
have known that in nine years he would
be the most famous black American
speaking at the march on Washington to
the largest gathering of civil rights
supporters in American history and he
could not have known that in fourteen
years he would be dead
he lost his life supporting a garbage
workers strike in Memphis the right to
decent work at decent pay of course
remains as basic to human freedom as the
right to vote Negroes he said in 1961
are almost entirely a working people
they're pitifully few Negro millionaires
and few Negro employers our needs are
identical to Labor's needs decent wages
fair working conditions livable housing
old age security health and welfare
measures conditions in which families
can grow have education for their
children respect in the community that
there are many many more black
millionaires today is a tribute to the
movement King led that they're
proportionately fewer black people
working today is an indictment of our
times and a reflection of our failure to
keep the movement coming on now he's not
the only soldier missing from the
freedom fight he was part of an army
that numbered tens of thousands while
all valued his leadership few waited for
his direction before an attack on
segregation began in countless southern
towns aggressive anti-segregation
activity had a history that began in
slavery time today we wait for others to
sanction our protests others to lead us
yesterday's movement was a People's
Movement it produced leaders of its own
it relied not on the noted but the
nameless not on the famous but the
faceless those were the days when good
music was popular and popular music was
good those were the days when the
president picked the Supreme Court and
not the other way around those are the
days those were the days when we had a
war on poverty and not a war on the poor
and those were the days when patriotism
was a reason for open-eyed disobedience
not an excuse for blind allegiance but
too many for too many the King holiday
and the Black History Month celebrations
that follow it have become occasions for
orgies of racial self-congratulation we
don't honor the man we honor his
imperfect memory we don't honor the
movement instead we honor the myth we
ought to remember that we honor dr.
King's birthday not his death day we
ought to imitate the well live life and
not simply mourn the martyrs death for
most of us he's little more than an
image seen in grainy black-and-white
television film pictures taken in
Washington 40 years ago the gifted
preacher who had a dream but King of
course was much more than that and the
movement much more than Martin Luther
King he did more than tell the nation
about his dream at the march on
Washington in the years before and after
he addressed the human condition the
larger world beyond America's Shores
racial justice economic equality world
peace these were the themes that
occupied his life they ought a cue pie
us today we meet as our nation is once
again on the brink of war in the Persian
Gulf War without a reason or rationale
when King spoke out against the war in
Vietnam in 1965 he was revolted at the
hypocrisy of America's claims for
freedom overseas when blacks enjoyed few
freedoms here how ironic it was he said
that black and white boys could die
together in foxholes in Vietnam and
couldn't go to school together in
Georgia that widened war abroad stole
from Americans here at home how sadly
true those words ring today we also meet
in the aftermath of a terrible day in
American life in history the slaughter
of almost 3,000 innocents those who died
on September 11th were a diverse group
most Americans but they died with people
for more than 50 countries from Chile
through Zimbabwe that's why they called
it the World Trade Center among the
Americans were blacks whites Latinos
Asians Christians Muslims Jews as
diverse in death as we are in life a
black doctor who volunteered to work at
Ground Zero said down there it wasn't a
matter of race or creed or political
affiliation it was just everyone
pitching in and we'd all talk about this
being the way America should be Martin
King talked about that too about his
dream that one day his children would be
judged by the content of their character
and not by the color of their skin he
said that was a dream and it sadly
remains a dream today one of those who
escaped from the World Trade Center said
if you'd seen what it was like in that
stairway you'd be proud
there was no gender no race no religion
it was everyone helping each other but
away from that stairway back in
America's streets there is gender there
is race there is religion since the
attacks people who look like Muslims are
Arabs have been harassed assaulted and
even killed on the Saturday following
that terrible Tuesday in Mesa Arizona a
gunman shot to death the sikh owner of a
gas station fired on a lebanese clerk at
work
and an Afghan family at home when he was
arrested the suspect said I'm a patriot
I'm a damn American all the way what he
really is is a damn fool
we know America's twin towers Freedom
and Justice are standing still it's our
job to keep upright what others would
weaken and destroy America's strongest
when she is just and she is fiercest
when her people are free less than a
week after the attacks president george
w bush went to the Washington Islamic
Center standing in his stocking feet the
president vowed to prevent hate crimes
and discrimination against Arabs and
Muslims in the wake of these attacks he
renewed this vow on the first
anniversary of the attacks and so our
nation's two stated goals retaliation
against terrorists abroad promotion of
Tolerance here at home a reminiscent of
the double V campaign waged by blacks
during World War two it symbolized
victory against fascism abroad victory
against racism here at home with the
events of September 11th we realized
we've not yet achieved either victory
not yet against tyranny abroad not yet
against racism here at home just as this
enemy terrorism is more difficult to
identify and punish so is discrimination
a more elusive target today no more
designs read white and colored the law
now requires the voters booth and
schoolhouse door to swing open for
everyone no longer are they closed to
those whose skins are dark but despite
impressive increases in the number of
black people holding public office
despite our ability to city dried vote
go to school in places that used to bar
black faces in some important ways
non-white Americans face problems more
difficult to attack now than in all the
years that went before senator Trent
Lott uncovered a running sore almost
fifty years old that if allowed to
fester threatens to imperil our very
democracy it is the longtime dependence
of the
can party on the politics of racial
division to win elections and gain power
by playing the race card an election
after election they've appealed to the
dark underside of American culture to
that minority of Americans who've
rejected democracy and equality encoded
racial appeal after appeal they draped
themselves in the Confederate flag they
embrace Confederate leaders as Patriots
and they wallow in a victim mentality
they preach racial neutrality and
practice racial division they celebrate
Martin Luther King and misuse his
message their idea of reparations is to
give war criminal Jefferson Davis a
pardon their idea of equal rights is the
American and Confederate flags flying
side-by-side their idea of compassion is
to ask the guests at the millionaire's
banquet if they want an extra helping or
a second dessert and where are the
Democrats with some notable exceptions
they're absent without leave from this
battle for America's soul they to
practice the politics of race avoidance
playing lip service to lifting all boats
but the truth is that while a few sail
lawn and luxury liners most are crammed
in the cargo hold and for those in the
deepest darkest underbelly of the boat
it's leaking under our seats for many
African Americans the 90s were more
financial bust than boom as the economic
uncertainties and layoffs mount the last
hired become the first fired joining
unemployment rolls already populated by
twice the percentages of blacks than
whites income inequality already greater
here than in most industrial democracies
has grown wider the wealthiest 1% of
American households now own more than
40% of all assets the top 20% earned 13
times what the bottom 20% earned and
corporate CEOs now make 419 times the
hourly wages of production workers these
imbalances not only mean difficult
economic times for many they also
undermine democratic values the danger
is that plutocracy will prevail over
democracy that the free market will rule
free citizen civil rights forces warned
that great harm would come from the
foolish risky tax bill of 2001 it's
become clear our warnings were
absolutely right it did not stimulate
economic growth it did not provide tax
relief for most Americans in fact it
succeeded only in fulfilling the worst
predictions of those who opposed it it
squandered a once-in-a-lifetime budget
surplus on an unwise tax cut that
primarily benefited the wealthy and it
continues to threaten Medicare and the
Social Security trust funds to make up
for these tax cuts we'd have to cut
spending by 5 billion dollars a year
five billion dollars five days a week
for over a year after all that was the
whole point to further enrich the
already wealthy and to starve the
government making it unable to meet
human needs the quality of public
education is declining 40 million
Americans have no health insurance
the proportion of poor children in
America higher than in any developed
nation and now they propose to make
matters even worse this is what the
country could do with the billions Bush
wants to give the rich by eliminating
dividend taxes we could treat 3.6
million Americans with living with HIV
and AIDS we could put a hundred thousand
community police officers on America's
streets we could fund almost every
emergency room in America we can
underwrite a year's worth of school
lunches for 43 million children and we
can provide one dinner 365 days a year
for 50 million senior citizens but we
have a president who talks like a
populist and governs for the privileged
we have an attorney general who's a
cross between J Edgar Hoover and Jerry
Falwell and
and we have a Senate Majority Leader
who's voted consistently against labor
rights against civil rights and against
women's rights and he's the one who
replaced the bad guy all too often one
political party is shameless and the
other is spineless only one senator only
one senator russell Feingold of
Wisconsin voted against the first
hastily prepared and ill-considered
terrorism measure proposed after
September 11th senator Feingold
explained his vote this way if we lived
in a country that allowed the police to
search our home at any time for any
reason if we lived in a country that
allowed the government to open your mail
eavesdrop on your phone conversations or
intercept your email communications if
we lived in a country that allowed the
government to hold people indefinitely
in jail based on what they write or
think or based on mere suspicion that
they're up to no good
then the government would no doubt
discover and arrest more terrorists but
that probably would not be a country in
which we would want to live nor do we
want to live in a country that permits
infiltration and surveillance of
religious and political organizations
yet the new FBI guidelines proposed by J
Edgar Ashcroft do just that just as we
remember J Edgar Hoover we remember his
counterintelligence program called
COINTELPRO and whose intelligence did
they want a counter in a program called
racial matters the FBI tried to disrupt
the civil rights movement they tried to
smear Martin Luther King they not only
wanted him discredited they wanted him
dead they threatened him with the
release of damaging information if he
did not take his own life
we thought we'd put a stop to Hoover's
programs of spies and lies in the 1970s
after these abuses were exposed now
under the guise of fighting terrorism
the FBI is going back to spying on
law-abiding citizens war and fear often
caused hasty mistakes costly both an
economic and in human terms
as the drums of war beat louder we ought
to remember what we're fighting for in
the summer of 1918 on the eve of
America's entry into World War one one
of the founders of the n-double a-c-p
dr. WB Dubois
urged black Americans to forget our
special grievances close ranks shoulder
to shoulder with our fellow citizens and
the Allied nations that are fighting for
democracy the criticism he faced then
was immediate and loud
he quickly reversed his position and
realized then as we must now that calls
for a retreat from our rights are always
wrong
he understood then as we must now that
when wars are fought to save democracy
the first casualty is usually democracy
itself that's why we must be vigilant
against the steady erosion of American
values and the basic rights we hold dear
we ought to remember the words of Ohio
Senator Robert Taft you know I never
thought I'd be quoting Robert F we ought
to remember the words of Ohio Senator
Robert Taft who said two weeks after
Pearl Harbor had been attacked I believe
there can be no doubt that criticism and
time of war is essential to the
maintenance of any kind of democratic
government and the words of the late
Supreme Court Justice Thurgood Marshall
who said grave threats to Liberty often
common times of urgency but we're seeing
freedom shrink and fear expand we're
seeing patriotism contract rather than
expand the American spirit the FBI and
the CIA kept files on me in the 1960s
they may be keeping files on me today
but while they were watching and
following and photographing and
wiretapping those of us working
non-violently in the freedom movement a
wave of white terrorism was sweeping
across the south without challenge it
has taken 40 years and more to bring a
pitiful few of the terrorists of that
period to justice and it has taken 40
years and more to put in place a
framework for civil rights enforcement
which is now threatened on several
fronts the administration's judicial
nominees are hostile to the basic
principles of civil rights law and
Civil Rights enforcement they opposed
the core constitutional principle of
one-person one-vote they've supported
federal funding for racially
discriminatory schools they've tried to
rewrite the anti-discrimination laws
from the bench and they be roaded
congressional authority to pass laws
that protect civil rights they promise
to leave no child behind and defaulted
on the promise the 2004 budget does away
with 45 programs for children covering
rural education dropout prevention
physical education and more the Attorney
General has sought to undo the work of
career lawyers and the Justice
Department's Civil Rights Division among
those staffing the voting rights section
is a lawyer who helped run the purge of
Florida's voting rolls another is a
former senior counsel for the Miss named
center for Equal Opportunity founded to
fight laws requiring racial justice in
America organizations dedicated to
overturning the gains of the civil
rights movement are now dictated public
policy they've struck here at MIT and
they won't rest until white preference
is restored the very names of these
organizations the Institute for justice
the campaign for colorblind America the
American Civil Rights Institute are
fraudulent and their names are
frightening they've already stolen our
vocabulary and they want to steal the
just spoils of our righteous war
sophisticated and well-funded over the
past decade they've won several
victories in the plot to dismantle
justice and fair play for more than a
decade they've waged ideological war
against moderation in the federal
judiciary and they complained the
loudest when the extremists they support
are rejected
they've ascended to unprecedented
positions of power within the federal
government
there is a right wing conspiracy and its
operating out of the United States
Department of Justice and the office of
White House Counsel and the Office of
Civil Rights and the Department of
Education and the United States
Commission on civil rights where members
of the Federalist Society now sit they
and others have set their gunsights not
only on affirmative action but also on
title 9 the 30-year old law guaranteeing
gender equity
in higher education but there's an even
wider conspiracy than this an
interlocking network of funders groups
and activists who coordinate their
methods and their message they are the
money the motivation and the movement
behind school vouchers behind the legal
assaults on affirmative action behind
attempts to reapportionment ease out of
office and attacks on equity everywhere
they promote the politics of anxiety and
resentment they wallow in an imagined
victimhood where everyone is against
them their enemies are legion women and
minorities who don't know their place
and expansive culture free from the
suppression of the past and an America
growing more and more diverse every day
and they've had a small but prominent
collection of black hustlers and
huxter's on their payrolls for more than
20 years rather than mounts serious
campaigns for the affections and the
loyalties of black voters they prop up
bogus black substitutes and label them a
new generation assigning a generational
conflict to black Americans which
doesn't exist in any other group they
can't deal with the leaders of black
people choose for ourselves so they
manufacture promote and hire new ones
like ventriloquist dummies they speak in
their puppet masters voice but we can
see his lips move and we can hear his
money talk they've
[Music]
they financed a conservative
constellation of make-believe blackface
front organizations all of them hollow
shells with more names on the letterhead
than there are on the membership rolls
they're buying seats at the table of
influence and their purchasing blacks at
a few bucks ahead they want to make any
government consideration of race illegal
and thereby do away with our rights and
much of the legacy of the civil rights
movement including affirmative action
affirmative action was created to fight
what Supreme Court Justice Sandra Day
O'Connor called the unhappy persistence
of both the practice and the lingering
effects of racial discrimination
affirmative action is under attack now
not because it has failed but because it
has succeeded it created the sizeable
middle class that now constitutes 1/3 of
all black Americans in the late 1960s
the wages of black women in the textile
industry tripled from 1970 to 1990 the
number of black police officers lawyers
and doctors doubled black electricians
and college students tripled black bank
tellers more than quadrupled affirmative
action is the just spoils of a righteous
war the opponent's keep telling us that
it carries a stigma which attaches to
all blacks as if none of us ever felt
any stigma before the words affirmative
action were ever uttered
[Music]
why don't they ever make this argument
about the millions of whites who got
into Harvard or Yale because dad was an
alumnus the president's family has
enjoyed three generations of preferences
extra boost given to the children of
Yale alumni why don't they make this
argument about those who got a good job
because dad was president of the company
or President of the United States you
never see these people you never see
these people walking around with their
heads held low moaning that everybody in
the executive washroom is whispering
about how they got their jobs most of
our elite professions have long been the
near exclusive province of white men I
seriously doubt if a single one of these
men is suffering low self-esteem because
he knows his race and gender helped him
win his job B as we all know the Supreme
Court is about to decide the legality of
affirmative action in two cases from the
University of Michigan as quiet as it is
by those who declare themselves
colorblind in his name dr. King
supported affirmative action in 1963 he
said it's impossible to create a formula
for the future which does not take into
account that Society has been doing
something special against the Negro for
hundreds of years how then can he be
absorbed into the mainstream of American
life if we do not do something special
for him now in order to balance the
equation and equip him to compete on a
just and equal basis
President Bush chose dr. King's birthday
to announce that even though society
continues to do something special
against racial minorities his opponent
will not do anything for them
he's supporting the opponents of
Michigan's efforts to promote diversity
among its student body the president
characterized Michigan's program as a
quota which it is not his use of this
charge word is an attempt to disguise
his failure to support justice he
complained that black and other minority
candidates
given extra points toward admission not
because the president said of life
experience but solely because of race
but in this country life experience is
determined by race they like to use they
like to use Secretary of State Colin
Powell a national security adviser
Condoleezza Rice as human shields
against any criticism of their record on
civil rights after all after all the
president is proud of boasting his
administration is the most diverse in
history except the one that preceded it
but but the day after the administration
filed its brief in the Michigan case
miss rice issued a rare statement on a
domestic issue saying it is appropriate
to use race as one factor among others
in achieving a diverse student body and
miss rice has acknowledged that
affirmative action was responsible for
her employment at Stanford University
secretary Powell for his part has long
been an outspoken advocate for
affirmative action and has specifically
said he hopes the University of Michigan
prevails in court as the Michigan law
school dean wrote color blindness as an
ideal not an idle and the Constitution
does not require us to sacrifice
effective education and integration in
its name or as I put it rather race is a
burden or benefit is all the same to
these theorists that's what they mean
when they speak of being colorblind they
are colorblind all right blind to the
consequences of being the wrong color in
America today
no group of Americans is more physically
isolated from jobs than blacks black
people seeking housing know these
consequences to more than one in five
blacks trying to buy a home or rent an
apartment face illegal discrimination
and black people who face
disproportionate surveillance arrests
and incarceration know these
consequences to one in three black men
carries the lifelong stigma of being a
felon
thank to this nation's racially
disparate war on drugs this
discrimination has real and measurable
cost or put another way eliminating it
would have measurable benefits but for
discrimination black Americans would
have 2 million more high school degrees
2 million more college degrees 700,000
more jobs and 700,000 blacks would not
be behind bars behind these numbers our
names and numerous benefits for society
at large we're such a young nation so
recently removed from slavery that only
my father's generation stands between
Julian Bond and Human Bondage like many
others I'm the grandson of a slave my
grandfather was born in 1863 in Kentucky
freedom didn't come for him until the
13th amendment was ratified in 1865 he
and his mother were property like a
horse or chair as a young girl she'd
been given away as a wedding present to
a new bride and when that bride became
pregnant her husband that's my
great-grandmother's owner and master
exercised his right to take his wife
slave as his mistress that Union
produced two children one of them my
grandfather at age 15 barely able to
read or write he hitched his tuition a
steer to a rope and walked a hundred
miles across Kentucky to Berea College
and the college led him in 16 years
later he graduated and the college asked
him to deliver the commencement address
he said then the pessimists from his
corner looks out on the world of
wickedness and sin and blinded by all
that is good and hopeful in the
condition and the progress of the human
race
but Wales the present state of affairs
and predicts woeful things for the
future in every cloud he be holds a
destructive storm in every flash of
lightning an omen of evil and in every
shadow that falls across his path a
lurking foe he forgets that the clouds
also bring life and hope that lightning
purifies the atmosphere that shadow and
darkness prepare for sunshine and growth
and that hardships and adversity nerve
the race as the individual for greater
efforts and grander victories greater
efforts and grander victories that was
the promise made by the generation born
slavery more than 140 years ago that was
the promise made by the generation that
won the great world war for democracy
more than five decades ago that was the
promise made by those who brought
democracy to America's darkest corners
four decades ago and the promise we must
all seek to honor today the Civil War
that freed my grandfather was fought
over whether blacks and whites shared a
common humanity less than ten years
after it ended the nation chose sides
with the losers and agreed to continue
black repression for almost a hundred
years 246 years of slavery followed by
hundred years of state sanctioned
discrimination reinforced by public and
private Terror ended only after a
protracted struggle in 1965 thus it has
only been a short 38 years that all
black Americans have exercised the full
rights of citizens only 38 years since
legal segregation was ended nationwide
only 38 years since the right to
register and vote was universally
guaranteed only 38 years since the
protections of law and constitution were
officially extended to all and now some
are telling us those 38 years have been
enough to believe that is the victory of
Hope over experience to believe that is
the victory of self-delusion over common
sense the modern movement for civil
rights has its immediate origins in the
Supreme Court's decision in Brown v
Board in 1954 that ruling effectively
ended segregations legality but it also
gave a nonviolent movement the license
to challenge segregations morality as
well a year after Brown and
n-double-a-cp activists in Montgomery
Alabama refused to give up her seat on a
city bus so a white man could sit down
five years after Montgomery four young
men
college students in Greensboro North
Carolina refused to give up their seats
at a dime-store lunch counter reserved
for whites these small acts of passive
resistance to American apartheid and the
cumulative acts of tens of thousands
more helped created a People's Movement
that eliminated legal segregation in
less than a decade we ought not forget
that
stood at the head of thousands people
who made the mighty movement what it was
from jamestown slave pens to
Montgomery's boycotted buses these
ordinary women and men labored in
obscurity and from Montgomery forward
they provided the foot soldiers of the
freedom army they walked in dignity
rather than ride in shame
they faced bombs and Birmingham and mobs
in Mississippi they sat down at lunch
counters so others could stand up King
didn't march from Selma to Montgomery by
himself he didn't speak to an empty
field at the march on Washington there
were thousands marching with him and
before him and thousands more who did
the dirty work that preceded the
triumphant March black Americans didn't
March to freedom we worked our way to
civil rights through the difficult
business of organizing knocking on doors
one by one registering voters one by one
developing a community block by block
creating an effective organization town
by town but the removal over the decades
of the 1960's of the more blatant forms
of American apartheid have made it too
easy for too many to believe today that
all forms of discrimination have
disappeared opinion polls revealed that
a majority of whites think racial
discrimination is no longer a major
impediment for people of color in one
study seventy-five percent of whites
said blacks faced no discrimination in
obtaining jobs or housing even as such
discrimination daily becomes more severe
polls show most white Americans believe
equal educational opportunity exists
right now even as our schools are
becoming more not less segregated across
the country the successful strategies of
the modern movement were litigation
organization mobilization and coalition
all aimed at creating a national
constituency for civil rights today's
times require no less and in fact insist
on more we now find ourselves refighting
old battles we thought we'd already won
facing new problems we barely begun to
acknowledge but we ought to take heart
if there's more to be done we have more
to do it with much more than those who
came before and who bought us along this
farm as a nation we have more than a
century's worth of aggressive self-help
and volunteerism in church
Club Neighborhood Association providing
scholarships helping the needy financing
the cause of social justice but
volunteerism alone and social service
alone do little to change the status quo
creating change requires a critical
analysis of power in society and a
commitment to both challenging and
changing inequality it's never enough
just to ignore evil it's never enough
just to do good it's never enough just
to feed the hungry and house the
homeless as commendable as these acts
are it may be helpful to think about our
common tasks in this way two men are
sitting by a river and to their horror
see a helpless baby come floating by
they jump in and save the child and to
their surprise another child comes down
the stream they jump in the water the
third second time and saved the baby and
who there are a third baby comes down
one of the men jumps in the water a
third time and the other begins to run
upstream come back says the man in the
water we've got to save this child you
save it says the running man I'm gonna
find out who's throwing babies in the
water and I'm gonna make him stop now I
recently heard professor Lani Guinier
say that racial minorities alike the
Canaries that miners used to carry to
warn them when the underground air was
becoming too toxic to breathe but too
many people today want to put gas masks
on the Canaries instead of taking the
poison out of the air
too many want to put life preservers on
the babies instead of stopping them from
being thrown in a treacherous dangerous
flood we have a long and honorable
tradition of social justice in this
country it still sends forth the message
that when we act together we can
overcome it is a serious mistake
both tactical and moral to believe this
is a fight that must or should be waged
by black Americans alone that has never
been so in centuries past it ought not
be so in this century unfolding now a
civil rights agenda for the new century
must include continuing to litigate to
organize to mobilize forming coalition's
of the caring and concerned joining
ranks against the comfortable the
callous and the smug we must demand fair
treatment for people with HIV and AIDS
especially people of color we have to
ensure that our children and suburban
integrated schools and segregated
schools in rural America or the inner
city receive the best education an
education that prepares them for the
century ahead none of this is easy work
but we've never wished our way to
freedom instead we've always worked our
way by the year 2050
blacks and Hispanics together will be
40% of the nation's population this
growth in immigration and the emergence
of new and vibrant populations of people
of color holds out great promise and
great peril the promises that the
Coalition for justice will grow larger
and stronger as more and more allies
during the fight the peril comes from
real fears that our common foes will
find ways to separate and divide us it
doesn't make sense if blacks and Latinos
argue over which has the least amount of
power
together we can constitute a mighty
force for change we know our lives and
our world change forever on September
11th we don't know yet by how much but
we know we have a job to do at home as
much as abroad when I first started
working for decades ago there were five
workers paying in the retirement system
for every retiree of course there's no
way I could possibly know who my five
were but there's a good chance their
names could have been Carl Ralph
Bob Steve and Bill when I retire they're
gonna be three workers paying in the
retirement system for every retiree and
there's a good chance their names will
be Tamika Maria and Jose and I'm here to
tell you you better make sure that
Tamika Maria and Jose have the best
schools the best health care the best
jobs and the strongest protections
against discrimination they possibly can
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone please join me in thanking Mr
Bond for his insightful and profound
[Music]
thank you so much Chancellor clay when I
recognized the 2002-2003 Martin Luther
King jr. visiting professors Chancellor
clay another toughie son wonderful
speech
mit has been fortunate over the last
decade to have an hour missed visiting
minority faculty who come to our
community sometimes its former alums
sometimes his neighbors from nearby to
provide an opportunity for us to
interact and learn from them and an
opportunity for them to participate in
our community we are fortunate to have
several of those faculty in our myths
today so I will introduce them and ask
them to stand at the end of the
introduction first I want to welcome
Professor Xavier de Souza brakes who's
visiting the department of urban studies
and planning from his position as a
public policy professor at Harvard
University I want to welcome Professor
Jonathan Farley professor of mathematics
at Vanderbilt University who's visiting
us from his visiting physician as a
distinguished Fulbright professor at
Oxford University professor Sarkozy
Matenga
is visiting with us from North Carolina
A&T University he's not here with us
today because he along with professor
Peters who's visiting with us
they are both and at a conference on
physics in Atlanta and we can excuse
them if they bring back to us
prospective faculty and graduate
students we're also delighted to have
visiting with us professor olafemi olofi
who's visiting our department of
material science and engineering
from visiting with us from University of
Delaware professor Peters who I
mentioned earlier is a graduate of MIT
and is visiting with us from Duke
University and I want to ask them to
stand in a moment but there are a couple
of other people who are visiting
scholars professor Otis Jennings is
visiting the Sloan School of Management
he's visiting from Georgia Tech and
professor mark Lloyd who is a attorney a
lawyer a journalist is visiting the
Department of Urban Studies and planning
so let me ask all of them to stand and I
want to thank them for being a part of
our community this year and welcome them
and introduce them to you
[Applause]
when I have the MIT gospel choir lead us
in singing lift every voice and sing by
James Weldon Johnson we have to to stand
and please join in song
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for that outstanding radition
of lift every voice and sing you mean
I'll be seated
now as Reverend Johanna Kyler to come
forward to give the benediction to close
this morning's program
Reverend Kaiser send us to be a people
generous with our abundance send us to
restore one another with compassion send
us with vision that we may see
inequality and injustice with an
unclouded I send us with the power to
work for justice send us with courageous
hearts to be peacemakers and may you
bring all this wonderful and hurting
world into its blessed fullness may we
live to see that great and glorious day
amen I hope you have enjoyed this
morning's program it's been a wonderful
event which I'm sure will made our
thoughts for a long time thank you all
for coming and we hope to see you next
year this concludes our 29th annual
Martin Luther King jr. celebration have
a wonderful day
[Applause]